on attend beaucoup de monde demain à
paris pour la manifestation organisée
par sos racisme
alors aujourd'hui une polémique au coeur
d'une commune ile de france prend un
relief tout particulier
en effet peut-on être mère et raciste
c'est la question posée à montfermeil en
seine-saint-denis par un certain nombre
d'organisations dont la ligue des droits
de l'homme et la cfdt
d'après elle le maire de la ville refuse
l'accès à l'école pour les enfants des
familles émigrées dominique bâillon
marque doux la cité des bosquets à
montfermeil un de ces grands ensembles
où on a entassé les immigrés une cité où
les problèmes sont déjà nombreux alors
doit-on encore en ajouter un autre en
refusant l'accès à l'école des jeunes
enfants aux maghrébins ou afrique
c'est pourtant ce qui se passe par
décision municipale pour inscrire ses
enfants à l'école il faut d'abord
obtenir une autorisation de la mairie
mais à chaque rentrée le maire et
conduit systématiquement les familles
d'immigrés qui viennent d'arriver dans
la commune on m'a dit que je prends pas
les enfants et nous on en a marre
cette année six familles se sont vu
refuser l'accès à l'école maternelle
victor hugo une école où il est vrai les
immigrés représentent déjà 85 % des
élèves puis 3-1 en effet c'est la même
chose toutes les rentrées scolaires à
montfermeil le maire vous plus de
prendre dans les écoles des enfants en
afrique sont étrangers d'abord vous êtes
attaqués aux enfants d'âge primaire la
civilité et d'autres organisations se
sont mobilisés et ont gagné aujourd'hui
tous les enfants sont scolarisés dans
les écoles primaires mais maintenant
colmatée
pourtant pour nous c'est le même
problème la loi est claire il ne doit
pas y avoir de discrimination entre les
enfants français et dont jean pierre
bernard le maire de montfermeil a refusé
de répondre à nos questions mais sa
prose est suffisante pour apprécier son
attitude dans le bulletin municipal il
explique franchement son ras-le-bol de
la population immigrée il n'en veut plus
sur sa commune il le dit également dans
les courriers qu'il adresse aux familles
émigrées par décision du bureau
municipal lors dit il toute inscription
d'étrangers à l'école maternelle est
interdite
et il ajoute vous n'avez qu'à demander
un logement dans une autre commune
visiblement pierre bernard n'a pas
encore eu le temps de lire le récent
rapport
député rpr michel hannoun sur le racisme
mais peut-être prendra-t-il le temps de
lire le télégramme envoyé hier par le
préfet de seine saint denis pour
l'obliger à revenir sur sa position
ou bien sera-t-il sensible à l'image de
cet enfant pour qui les grilles de
l'école reste hermétiquement closes